mics in Fort Smith Ohio hey Mike what's
your net worth 2.8 million who'll break
that down for me how's that invested
mutual funds and stocks in the primary
part about 2.3 and in the home and the
70 acres is set songs about a half a
million okay all right very cool
and how old are you sir 65 65 good and
how much of the 2.8 million is there
because you inherited it a URL okay cool
and what was your range household income
range during your working lifetime my
first year work of a whopping seventy
eight hundred dollars and at the end of
my career topped out at about one
hundred and eighty thousand a year so
what you do for a living I was a
restaurant management person served off
as a actually as a busboy and worked up
and I finished as a vice president had a
regional company gotcha
you got a four-year degree no I actually
just had a two-year technical degree
okay and what business management okay
all right very cool obviously that was
only a year and a half because the
second part of your year you went and
did a job and wrote a paper on it so
it's actually a year and a half of
college got you what was your GPA in
that 3.2 good for you okay cool and how
much of the 2.8 is there because you
borrowed money to create wealth 0 we've
actually never had deaths in her life
wow that's pretty impressive
yeah you may actually we did basically
what your book teaches isn't before
there was a book 42 years of marriage
we've never made a single car payment
never had credit card gun never had
college debt we didn't had three homes
that we had mortgages on for three homes
in a row five years and we would pay off
the mortgages and the fourth home with
it then now we built for cash what
advice would you give to the 25-year old
version of you can this still be done
and if so what do they do
it's basically the principles that you
teach it's stay out of debt and save
money consistently it's the turtle
versus the hare I'm definitely the
turtle you never made any big scores
that always semesters and
slow anything very cool congratulations
Mike it's an honor to talk to you sir
and by the way I just got through type
teaching your piece University at our
church well thank you I think you've got
credibility when you're standing up in
front of that class 2.8 million dollar
net worth it's a millionaire theme our
talking to real millionaires not your
broke brother-in-law with an opinion
this is the Dave Ramsey show